مصدر قلق امريكي جديد من الصين الملف هو
التجسس والمكان هو كوبا الاداره الامريكيه
تحاول التعامل مع هذا الخطر وفق بوليتيكو
رغم نفي البيت الابيض والبنتاجون قيام
الصين بانشاء القاعده ووسط اللغط الذي
احيط بهذه القضيه اكد مسؤول امريكي ان
الصين انشات بالفعل قاعده تجسس في كوبا
وان اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اطلعت
على عدد من القواعد الحساسه في جميع انحاء
العالم ومن ضمنها القاعده الموجوده في
كوبا منذ يناير العام 2021
المصدر نفسه اكد ان بكين انشات هذه
القاعده منذ العام 2019 وليس كما افادت
المعلومات بانها اتفقت مع هذانا على
انشائها مستقبلا بايدن وبحسب المسؤول
الامريكي وجه ادارته بمعالجه تلك القضيه
خلال اشهر دون الافصاح عن مزيد من
التفاصيل مسؤولون امريكيون مطلعون على
معلومات استخباراتيه سريه للغايه لفتوا في
وقت سابق الى ان تلك المنصه التي ستقام في
الجزيره على بعد حوالي 100 ميل من فلوريدا
الامريكيه ستتيح لاجهزه المخابرات الصينيه
الحصول على الاتصالات الالكترونيه في جميع
انحاء جنوب شرقي الولايات المتحده حيث
توجد العديد من القواعد العسكريه وفق ما
نقلت صحيفه وولز
وجود مثل تلك القاعده ذات القدرات
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه المتقدمه في
الفناء الخلفي لامريكا يشكل بلا شك تهديدا
صينيا جديدا غير مسبوق بالنسبه لواشنطن
لاسيما وسط ارتفاع مستوى التوتر بين
البلدين منذ فتره اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات